why are these people in Palestine Ohio
getting all of the attention this is a
small train derailment with 11 cars with
a few toxic chemicals a control burn in
the air that's uh giving people
um headaches for days they can't sleep
and their pets are dying but other than
that I don't see a huge problem here and
I think really this is just again a
bunch of people in the middle of Ohio
that want to go Hollywood and less than
five to ten minutes after I started
smelling it my son woke up out of a dead
sleep violently shaking throwing up and
it was shortly just a few minutes after
I started smelling it so at that point I
took them there kids have nightmares I
mean is this woman new let's let's see
someone else because I Feel Like This
Woman's a liar and I don't like liars
are you all back back working in there
is the debt building damage oh yeah they
as soon as the evacuation lifted they
were back in work of course back to work
I like it back to work this is good